a contractor is purchasing some stone
tiles for new patio each tile costs $3
and he wants to spend less than $1000
and it's less than $1,000 not less than
or equal to a thousand the size of each
tile is one square foot write an
inequality that represents the number of
tiles he can purchase with a one
thousand dollar limit and then figure
out how large the stone patio can be so
let X let X be equal to the number of
tiles purchased tiles purchased and so
the cost of purchasing X tiles they're
going to be three dollars each so it's
going to be three X so three X is going
to be the total cost of purchasing the
tiles and he wants to spend less than
$1000 three X is how much he spends if
he buys X tiles it has to be less than
$1000 we say it right there if it was
less than or equal to it would have a
little equal sign right there so if we
want to solve for X how many tiles can
he buy we can divide both sides of this
inequality by three and because we're
dividing or multiplying you can imagine
we're multiplying by 1/3 or dividing by
three because this is a positive number
we do not have to swap the inequality
sign so we are left with X is less than
1000 over 3 which is 333 and 1/3 so he
has to buy less than 330 3 and 1/3 tiles
that's how many tiles and each tile is
one square foot so if you can buy less
than 330 3 and 1/3 tiles then the patio
has to be so the size of the patio size
of the patio also has to be less than
333 and one third square feet feet
squared we could say square feet and
we're done